hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google I work on
graphics and animations and today I want
to talk about the new animation system
that came on in the 3.0 release
specifically I want to talk about object
animator and its ability to animate view
properties so let's take a look at a
demo which looks remarkably similar to a
demo we saw in a previous episode where
we were talking about view animations so
the point of today's demo is to show
basically how to do similar kinds of
things with the new animation system as
you could do with the old animation
system so we have some very boring
buttons on the screen with names of
animations that are going to run on the
buttons as we click on them so we have
an alpha animation that fades the button
in and out translate moves the button
around rotate spins it around scale and
then set runs the animations in sequence
now one thing to note about this demo
versus the view animation demo is that
you can use the choreography class
called animator set to actually run
different animations on different
objects it's easier to choreograph for
more complex animations where this
animator set is actually running
animations on several different objects
not just on the same button down there
regardless they're kind of ugly
animations is not what you'd want in
your application this is a little bit
more of about the technique of creating
and running these animations and also
just as in the previous demo where we
saw view animations created from
resources you can also create object
animator animations from resources as
well so we check the little box and we
can load and run the animations that are
then created from resources instead on
this one the actual the animation
resource is actually running on the same
button so we get that really egregious
effect of running these animations in
sequence on that single button ok demo
now terribly interesting code little
more interesting
so let's take a look at the code so we
have this class called property
animations we have the checkbox that
controls whether we're going to be
loading from resources or loading from
code we have the buttons that we create
here we're load-in from the resource the
layout resource and then we have the
animations that we create on the fly so
this is sort of the general way of how
you
create object animators to animate
specific properties on views let me
bring this code a little bit more in
line so you can actually see it on the
screen so we have an alpha animation
this is created by saying okay I want a
floating point animation there are all
these factory methods on object animator
as well as value animator to create and
then return one of these animator
objects so we're going to say object
animator dot of float and the target of
the animation is going to be the alpha
button that we found by ID above and
we're going to animate the property view
dot alpha now there's different ways to
do this the original way in 3.0 was to
actually use a string where you use a
word that is then associated with
setters and getters on the target object
so in this case we could use the string
alpha and then it's going to use
reflection or J&I to go in and look at
that target object you provided and say
is there a set alpha that I can call
during the animation and optionally it
may also look for a get alpha to derive
the original value that it starts from
but in I think it was 3.1 or 3.2 we
released a new property mechanism which
are these static objects on the view
class itself and there's slightly more
efficient so instead of using reflection
or J&I to get to those setters and
getters we can simply call directly into
a setter and getter directly in the
property object so slightly more
efficient I tend to prefer that when I'm
animating few properties so we've said
okay I want to animate the Alpha button
and when I animate I want to animate the
Alpha property on that button and I want
to animate it to a value of 0 note I
didn't tell it what value to start from
it's going to assume that it starts from
whatever value it has right now so it's
going to go ahead and call the property
object and say what about value do you
have now now animate it to 0 it has a
default duration unlike the old
animations which didn't have a default
duration the new object animator
animations have a default duration of
300 milliseconds so we don't need to set
that duration we're going to set a
repeat count of 1 2 which means we're
going to run once and then repeat once
after that and a repeat mode or reverse
so it's going to fade out and then back
in translate animation similarly we're
going to create an object animator of
float we're going to target the
translate button and we're going to
target the view Trane's
Asian X property and give it a value of
800 so this means it's going to start
from wherever it happens to be right now
which I happen to know is zero because I
wrote the app and it's going to animate
to a value of 800 repeat count of one
repeat mode of reverse which means it's
going to animate over the right and then
slide back over the left rotate
animation you're probably getting the
pattern by now we say object animator
dub float of the target that we want to
animate and the property on that target
we want to animate we're going to
animate from its current value which
happens to be 0 to a value of 360 so
it's simply going to spin a full loop
and by default is going to rotate around
its center and you can set the pivot
point for scale and rotation animations
if you want repeat count of one repeat
mode reverse so it's going to spin and
then it's going to spin back and then we
have a slightly more complex one for
scaling because we're going to animate
two properties at the same time the
scale X as well as the scale Y so we use
this other class called property values
holder and say I'm gonna want to
property values holder of float and
we're going to target these properties
on the object and we're going to scale
up from whatever it happens to be starts
with the default value of 1 up to a
value of 2 then we create a scale
animation and instead of being of float
we're going to say of property values
holder that's the target object these
are the property value holder objects
that we're going to use and again we're
going to repeat and reverse finally the
set animation this uses the animator set
class which provides an easy way for you
to have more interesting choreography of
multiple animations that can be
staggered in time or run together run
sequentially lots of different ways to
use this one of the things you'll notice
that there's this fluent API where you
can say I want to play the translation
animation and want to play that after
the alpha animation but before the
rotation animation sort of build up
these complex chains and then you start
the animation it figures out the tree
the graph of how these things
interrelate and then it executes all of
them in the order that you specified
then we call the setup animation which
says okay here's the objects that we
created above and alternately here's the
resource IDs that you'll want to run it
from the resource instead so we go into
that method where we set up and run the
animation and if the checkbox is checked
then we need to load the resource first
and this is something to be aware of you
we are going to use animator resources
they don't have a concept of instances
and the resources so after you load the
resource and you have your animator
object then you need to set a target on
it so there knows what target you're
actually trying to animate so we're
going to set the target then we start
the animation alternatively if we're not
if we're not launching from the resource
we're not creating from the resource
were instead creating from the codes
that we had above for creating the
animations then we simply call start on
them let's take a look at some of the
resources for how we create these things
we have an object animator tag and we
pass in property names which should make
sense they were sort of created that way
so we have a property name we're going
to animate alpha we're going to repeat
it once and reverse it duration at 300
milliseconds and a value to zero so it's
simply going to fade out and then since
it's reversing it's going to fade back
in we have a move animation again
similar to what we saw in code scale
animation this one is the ones actually
has two properties that are being
animated in parallel instead of using
property values holder I happen to be
using an animator set here where we
create two object animators on the
different scale X and scale Y properties
spin is going to do a rotation animation
and then finally this combo file is an
animator set which is going to run all
of these sequentially and it's going to
run it all on the same target object
there so this is the new property
animation system so if you're running
code from 3.0 onwards it's a more robust
animation system where you can target
these view properties as well as any
arbitrary target and arbitrary property
and we'll see some of that in future
episodes thanks